head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard
charts we ended up with two uh or I
should say we ended up with a wide range
of extremist beliefs that we saw uh
manifest throughout the country such as
uh what would they call it nonp and POC
groups they began actually creating uh
in seatt I think it was Seattle there
was a library where when people were
allowed to come if you were white you
had to go in a white room only and if
you were not white you went to the not
not white room in Dearborn Michigan you
had the digital cafes this was during I
believe it was during Co and they said
everybody come hang out online and talk
in a chat room but if you're white you
go in the room only for white people and
if you're not white you go in the room
only for not white people for instance
uh an example of this Derrick Bell
Pioneer of critical race Theory actually
argued that Brown should not have
dismantled py versus Ferguson a core
component of critical race theory is
that schools should remain segregated so
in S I believe it was Sacramento's
School District they created white
racial Affinity groups based on critical
race Theory I think I think that should
be a lot in schools and if teachers are
teaching critical race practice to
children I believe it's illegal under
the 1964 Civil Rights Act and should be
barred from schools yeah but what we end
up with once again is you're Banning
books conservatives are Banning books
real but some of the books that they're
banning some of the books that they're
banning Grapes of Wrath yes Grapes of
Wrath is one of the the top 100 uh most
uh um band books Grapes of Wrath the
Portrait of Dorian Gray because someone
has a homosexual feeling um or we even
talking about to Kill a Mocking Bird so
I I I don't think we have to separate
this I mean some things are just kind of
outrageous no matter what your politics
are but other things I think American
children should learn our history and I
think they should learn great great
books of literature great works of art
um I think we all agree okay good so we
don't have to turn this into a war but I
think the issue is if say Ronda santis
comes out and he put this on
florida.com uh or I should say they did
actually I think no this is Rhonda
santis the books they banned were gender
queer flamer this book is gay and let's
talk about it books that contained
pornographic and adult materials and
instruction on those things for junior
high school this is Middle School I
wouldn't want that but so the issue then
becomes the W the media widely reports
he's just Banning books in general when
you get I mean this is this is Ronda
santis from his own mouth saying these
are the books we banned and why we
banned them but then all of a sudden the
corporate press just says he's Banning
books in general and and the
conversation shifts from we don't want
children getting access to adult content
to the perspective which you have is oh
they're trying to ban books like grapes
of no that's not the pp that's that's
not what I just said I agree with you
that there are books that I would not I
don't I'm not comfortable with the
governor doing it but there are books uh
with over sexual or whatever uh at a
certain young age that I just would be
fine with the um uh with the school
board saying um too young this is like
um like you were saying when you were
younger ideas of like racism were just
shameful and that Society wouldn't allow
those things to get a mainstream
megaphone and now it's similar with
books we're in the age of
self-publishing people
can can publish ideas without a central
Authority like saying hey that's a
little publisher there's no gatekeeper
yeah and so the that we kind of have to
to be more Vigilant in our censorship
methods well I think that that nothing
is a substitute for an ethical
Revolution we all have to just uh that's
why the work of just what is an ethical
person you can't there is no substitute
for that I I I have a problem with with
the the your your talk of censorship
just because it's one thing to to like I
we' talked about you know what can go
into um libraries and stuff and it's one
thing to to curate what goes into school
libraries and stuff like that censorship
is a totally different animal I think
it's a form of censorship curation well
I want a general I don't I mean a
library curates an art director curates
a a somebody curated what was on the
wall here oh yeah mostly me sensor is
mostly a neutral term it's just you're
you're looking at something and deeming
is this permissible or is it not in the
current situation I think I think
curation is neutral censorship is not
neutral well you can censor something
and allow it so what you're if you
censor something you're just deciding
yes or noens versus sensor um I think
when you cens censoring is just the act
of observing and deciding yes or no
censoring is when you is specifically
removing information it can be good or
bad what about these great works of art
uh you were talking about the things you
were talking about many of us are upset
about things like to Kill a Mocking BG
Grapes of Wrath uh but we all agree on
that and I think we all agree on lot of
the stuff yeah but so this is this is
more ambiguous I'm curious your thoughts
on this that's kind of hard to read I I
tried to find a higher resolution uh and
for the record I was right you were
wrong censure is a official rebuke or an
expression of strong disapproval yeah
but a censor CNR is just the act of
deciding yes or no you can say yes
that's okay but you still censored it or
you can say no it's not okay and you
censored it it's sort of the opposite of
what yeah yeah and so sorry to interrupt
society's Tak I think I understand what
you're saying they become Society will
try and tell you that it means saying no
it only means saying no but it's just
the act of deciding yes or no is to
censor yes but by definition if you say
no you are censoring You could argue
that you said it's neutral but I don't
think it's neutral there's a reason why
it's censored um um I want to get uh uh
this is this is a more ambiguous example
of from a book in a school I'm curious
your thoughts are you able to see it I'm
trying to find a good high resolution
image of it but this is from a book
called not my idea particularly a page
from the book about contract binding you
to whiteness it says you get stolen land
stolen riches special favors whiteness
gets to mess endlessly with the lives of
your friends neighbors and loved ones
and all fellow humans of color for the
purpose of profit your soul sign below
land riches and favors may be revoked at
any time for any reason it depicts a uh
hoofed footed demon with fire on top of
with money on fire a Devil's Tail and a
hand reaching for a
handshake no I think that's terrible so
this is critical race practice when they
take the ideology from Derek Bell or
kimy kensaw and they put it in a
children's book and this is one of the
books they want removed from schools
whiteness is a bad deal it always was
dude we can see your pointy
tail this is what's in Great Schools and
this is this is the the reason why like
this is the stuff that that as much as
conservatives are are trying to get
stuff out and there there is going to be
or there are going to be attempts by um
more authoritarian conservatives to try
and attach their their limits on
people's rights and stuff like that
that's going to happen but at the same
time stuff like this your average person
doesn't even know like they're not even
aware and then when it's presented to
them by the media which you understand
exactly how how duplicitous and and and
difficult it can be with today's modern
media when it gets presented to the
average person by the media they do
everything they can to make this seem
like this isn't the situation they make
it seem like it's ba it's all racists
and all bigots and blah blah blah but
then you you actually look into it and
the situation is no there's really
objectionable stuff being placed in put
in schools that parents are objecting to
and then the FBI goes after the parents
for protesting you know this is this is
the government that that we have right
now this is the real federal government
FBI going after a parent because his kid
was was sexually assault this is state
level so in Virginia uh uh Lowden County
are you familiar with the lden County
Conflict which one's going so Lowden
county is about 30 seconds from here
Ladon County Virginia and there was a uh
I believe she was a pre-teen girl was
raped in the bathroom by a boy wearing a
dress the conservative uh uh
conservatives tend to reported as a
trans boy but I don't think the boy was
trans I think the boy was like
non-binary identifying or something just
wearing female clothes and using the
girl bathroom the thought the school
covered it up it led to a huge Scandal
which was a huge component in why noram
didn't win re-election and why yunan did
uh the father got arrested when he went
to the school board demanding to know
why the school covered up the rape of
his daughter so these are the these are
these are the extreme stories that are
popping up for the people who are you
know attuned to it the corporate press
of course is not talking about it so you
know I I think and they slander people
that do of course like I think much with
what you experience how they lie about
you it's so widespread it's actually
hard to break through I did just bring
up this site just to show you this not
my idea that the passage I just showed
you this is a children's book where they
say this about whiteness and uh I do
want to talk about this and and this is
I don't know I figure I'd bring this
this story up to see what your thoughts
are there's a movie coming out called
the American Society of magical Negroes
it's got people very angry because in
the trailer for the film they say uh
actually let me let me see if I can just
play this and I'll get your thoughts on
it let's see if we have uh might have to
unmute the site no we're
good step
step I know you can feel their
discomfort
Aaron watching you walk through a room
full of white people was the most
painful thing I've ever seen excuse me
sorry I don't want to take you to a job
interview there's a recruiting class
starting right now and we got to get you
in
it welcome to the Americans
Society of magical
Negroes I don't really understand it's
easier to
sh what's the most dangerous animal on
the planet sharks white people when they
feel uncomfortable white people feeling
uncomfortable precedes a lot of bad
stuff for us that's why we fight white
discomfort every day I'll pause right
there and say uh show this a meter
showing white tears next to a police
officer so the premise of this film is
that the most dangerous animal on the
planet is white people and a group of
secret magical black people have to use
magic powers to keep white people plated
otherwise the white people will turn on
them and kill them so this movie's got
everybody pissed off uh the root wrote
about it and they're actually angry many
well I shouldn't say they're angry but
there's a lot of criticism from more of
the left leaning people that it depicts
an interracial relationship which is
surprising I guess not really and then
the criticism from the right is that the
premise of the film is that white people
are the most dangerous animal on the
planet this is what people would refer
to as critical race practice in
mainstream media and film and this is a
ma this is a major movie this is like
you know Hollywood level production one
of the problem the question that comes
up for me is what you were saying before
is it better that stuff be out there and
that people hear it you know personally
I think it's better you know um but at
the same time like stuff like this like
this is is is hidden from
the public M and and until it it's burst
into an ugly form like this and it that
book which one not my idea that book
with a devil telling that kid you know I
mean it's it's all it's all so toxic and
so illiberal and there are people in and
the media misrepresents all of the
objections to it as coming from a place
of bigotry as coming from a place of
evil and stuff and I can understand that
so I understand this is why when it
comes to a show like ours we have every
conservative in the world emailing us
asking us to come on and not a single
liberal emails emails us asking us to
come on we actively have to fight to get
liberals come on the show wait a minute
let's look at me I'm I'm very leftwing
in my political views but I agree with
most of what that's why you're sitting
in this chair saying I I mean this to me
is it we're talking about a lot of
things here that I don't even see as
Left Right issues I agree do you they've
been turned into left right issues but
so the issue is when you have
high-profile prominent liberal or
leftist commentators who know exactly
what we're talking about they will not
come on this show because they would
have to put themselves in a position
where they're in opposition to their
tribe do you consider well I you know my
own tribe it's not very nice to me but
you see that's exactly it the people who
are trying to remain within the circle
of of the the dominant left
ideology have to agree with critical
race Theory and if they speak out
against it they will get cancelled they
will get banned from media they'll get
lied about they'll get smeared well
that's why I said earlier if if we could
just stay away from that term H the the
term is so is such a hot potato it's not
helpful it's this what we're talking
about here doesn't help to even talk
about in terms of critical race Theory
it seems to me but this is what critical
race theory is this is well but it's but
there are who would argue differently
but they're wrong well critical race
practice this is practice but but more
importantly when like we have the book
we have uh Chris Kimberly Creno's book
critical race Theory the core ideology
and it explicitly talks about what the
ideology means what it represents what
their goals are Derek Bell of course
famously said he thought plusy v
Ferguson was wrong and he wants
segregation in schools so when someone
comes out and says I would argue
critical race theory is something
different they are lying thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net